الابتكار والاستثمار هما المفتاح
لتسخير الإمكانات الكاملة
للطاقة المتجددة أنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
في الشارقة في المقر الرئيسي
لشركة النفايات البيئية ،
ويمكن أن يؤدي مشروع واحد إلى اختراق في
مجال الطاقة المتجددة في المنطقة التي
قابلت فيها بريكو خالد
لاكتشاف ما تفعله شركته
لتصبح أكثر استدامة
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، نحن هنا في أحد
أكبر
منشآت إعادة تدوير نفايات المواد
في العالم في الواقع ، هذا هو
أكبر مورف في الشرق الأوسط حيث
نعالج ما يقرب من
2000 طن  من النفايات يوميًا
عندما نبدأ ، فأنت تعلم التحدي الرئيسي
الذي تعلم أنه تم
إعدادنا للتعامل مع التحديات البيئية التي
تواجه منطقتنا ولكن المشكلة الرئيسية
التي نريد حلها كانت
إدارة النفايات ونحن على وشك الانتهاء
من بناء أول نفايات  إلى
محطة للطاقة في المنطقة ،
وسيساعدنا ذلك في
الوصول إلى هدفنا صفر من النفايات في السنوات
الماضية ، وضعنا جداول أعمال واضحة
جدًا من حيث الطاقة المتجددة  الطاقة الإلكترونية
من حيث تحويل النفايات ، نرى أيضًا أنها
تحدث في جميع أنحاء دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في العام الماضي ،
دخلنا المملكة العربية السعودية ودخلنا
مصر خلال الوباء ، لذا فقد كان
وقتًا صعبًا في مصر ، هدفهم
هو الوصول إلى تحويل نفايات 80
جيدًا.  إنها تعمل كيف
تفصل جيدًا ، لدينا عملية ميكانيكية
أنواع مختلفة من العمليات
التي تفصل بين جميع أنواع النفايات
وسنقوم بالفعل بتركيب روبوت
قريبًا جدًا والذي سيكون الأول في
المنطقة من خلال روبوت سيكون قادرًا على
الفصل  الأنواع المختلفة من الموجات من
خلال التعلم الآلي ،
حسنًا ، دعنا نتحدث عن الإمارات العربية المتحدة على
وجه التحديد ، نحن في أرض النفط والغاز ،
أعني أن هذا هو الخبز والزبدة ولكن مع
ذلك هناك رؤية وهناك
هدف لمحاولة جعل هذه المنطقة
أكثر من ذلك بكثير  ستكون الطاقة المستدامة والمتجددة
جزءًا من هذا نعم ، كيف
تلعب دورًا جيدًا
أحد المشاريع هو مشروع مشترك 50 50
يسمى شركة نفايات الإمارات إلى
طاقة ، لذلك نحن الآن نبني أو
نحن  سيؤدي حذف
مشروعنا الأول الذي يعالج
300000 طن من النفايات سنويًا ويولد
إلى توليد 30 ميغاوات من الطاقة
وهو ما يعادل تشغيل
ما يقرب من 28000 منزل.
وتم تشغيل محطة طاقة
النفايات لدينا ،
لن تكون هناك حاجة إلى مكب النفايات الخاص بنا بعد الآن ، لذلك نحن نبحث
كيف يمكنني إعادة توظيف مكب النفايات هذا ،
وتبلغ مساحة السطح حوالي 47 هكتارًا
سيتم تغطيتها جميعًا بألواح شمسية
بعد أن يتم تغطية مكب
النفايات وسيتم توليدها  120
ميغاوات إضافية من الطاقة المتجددة
مشروع آخر أيضًا
أعلنا عنه مؤخرًا هو نفاياتنا
للهيدروجين ، لذا سيكون هذا أيضًا واحدًا من
أوائل الشركات في العالم التي سنقوم فيها بتحويل
النفايات إلى هيدروجين وسنقوم
بشراء أسطول من الهيدروجين  شاحنات جمع النفايات المزودة بالطاقة ،
لذا ستكون
حلقة دائرية كاملة ، لذلك هذا
مشروع تجريبي واحد نعمل عليه
ونأمل أن نعلن عنه  أوقية المزيد عن ذلك قريبًا جدًا